new this morning the danger of Sids
sudden infant death syndrome it's
nothing new that it's something parents
always have to be aware of October is
Sid's awareness month and while it is
not sadly fully preventable there are
some things you can do to reduce your
baby's risk Candace Charles joining us
live from baby's Bounty this morning
Candace good morning
good morning you two good morning folks
babies Bounty provides a lot of links
for the communities for new mothers and
families one thing that I really love
that they provide is the baby bundle in
that you'll see something like this a
simple sign saying you've got this
really goes a long way but the most
important thing I would say is there's a
baby safe sleep kits now as you can see
it's also in Spanish of course they have
English versions here and I'm joined by
the executive director Kelly Maxwell
thank you so much for joining me tell me
a little bit about the kit and how the
safe sleep kit really does help yeah so
this is our complete baby bundle so
clients in need who qualify and take our
safe sleeping baby Basics course online
uh qualify for all of these items so all
of these that's a lot of items folks yes
it's 400 worth of items so it's a brand
new portable crib brand new infant
regulation car seat 25 items of clothing
the safe sleep kit we talked about a
front carrier bathing supplies bibs
rattles baby books everything you need
to care for a newborn for the first six
months of life and these are all new
items I mean folks they really do get
the donations and the grants to make
this all happen this weekend they had a
great Gala raise eighty thousand dollars
I mean how far can that go for folks
here in the community sure so as you can
imagine this is an expensive Endeavor
and we've provided about 9 000 of these
to the community so it's very expensive
we've got to keep up and now with
inflation things are even more expensive
so that eighty thousand dollars we raise
this weekend will go a long way towards
providing these items definitely and you
mentioned the safe sleep class only 30
minutes online and free most people
think about just the baby staying safer
than excuse me staying safe in the crib
but there's other places as well that
people need to be aware about right yes
so you should only be sleeping in infant
in a crib alone on their back not in a
swing not in a car seat long term not on
the you know mother's chest right not in
a chair you need to have the baby in a
crib each and every time because we know
that no level of risk is acceptable for
a newborn baby thank you so much Chloe
for the work that you do and for
speaking with us this morning we
appreciate it and of course you guys can
learn more details about the free safe
sleep class only 30 minutes on baby
Valley's website we'll have those
details for you on our website as well
as details for you guys to donate and
more just all the details you need to
know about babies bounty on our website
newsnow.com for now live from babies
Bounty I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now